so I'm getting Lasik yeah that's right
in 10 days well thank God because your
eyes are really small yeah I know thanks
so for 10 days before you get the
procedure you got to wear glasses right
and I've been wearing contacts for like
20 [__] two years or something
this has been my life as wearing
contacts yep
and so I've never worn glasses yeah like
I used to wear them maybe at night like
10 years ago but I remember yeah yeah
but even those were the wrong
prescription because I just never would
wear them so I wouldn't update them
right so then so then the doctor was
like when I went in for my consultation
he gave me
he gave me these and he's like these are
the right prescription you can wear
these for 10 days before
and I just knew I put these on I'm like
there's no [__] way I can wear these
yeah
especially to the podcast but here you
are like a real man no so then I had
these made Uh custom made because like
they look better
do they
I think they do yeah but they made the
they [__] up the prescription somehow
so now I can't see
and I'm and I'm going to Europe tonight
so I can't get new ones made so I'm
stuck with these that's perfect
which ones prescription these ones I
drove in these so anytime I want to look
cool I'm going to wear these
anytime I want to look like Rick Moranis
I'm going to wear it yeah yeah
so here let me try these on for you okay
so get a nice look at these right pretty
cool
right
what do you think no you look like a
caricature of a woman from the 1950s
like someone's wife making casserole or
something you look like that Meme or
like kind of that energy when I put
these on or oh my God I can actually see
yeah that's it's funny we both have eye
problems my
that dark spot in my left eye was going
away and now it's kind of back so I
think that means you're like retina is
detaching or something there's that but
that I have what's called CSR oh so it's
like when you get stressed out liquid
just gets in there
I actually think it's from some because
I've got eczema attack in my eyes oh
right right I think some a little cream
got in my eyes
were those actually cigarettes
oh you know it's great what did you
smoke it yeah I did I didn't feel
anything they're CBD cigarettes ah I
know it so you should be feeling really
relaxed oh yeah that's why I feel super
high right now but then you can counter
it with the coffee to get back on track
yeah I think you should wear the other
ones for your eye Health yeah I think
you should definitely wear the other
ones that work or not I mean it doesn't
affect your eyes when you can't see
yeah but it is a wrong prescription is
bad for your eyes no it's not yeah it is
for 10 days yes especially for 10 days
so then what was gonna happen the
lasik's gonna [__] up yeah yeah I'm
gonna be blind so I'm gonna wear the
wrong glasses just to look cool just for
10 days
yeah prescription glass like just
just wear this or just wear glasses no
you know prescription in it no you know
it's gonna be funny color
Cody's gonna wear the wrong prescription
get the Lasik and then have to wear
these
that's an ultimate punishment the
ultimate punishment [__] red yeah you
should put those on though yeah let me
let me see these yeah actually I want to
see you
let's see dude you are blind let's see
wait face me
actually you don't look that bad sorry
bro
I had to do it to him let me show you
how you rock these
they don't look that bad on him
[__] that hurts
oh my God man yeah get Lasik please
I'm working on it yeah I want you to
like have a life I'm working on I want
you to enjoy your existence I know I'm
I'm really looking forward to it but now
I gotta go to Europe
and like you know walk around one of
those beautiful cities in the world
where are you going to be I'm an expert
now
uh I don't know
well no we're going to this wedding
that's like 45 minutes outside of London
so it's like in a small town I don't
know what it's called I'm in Europe
that is the UK what that's the UK yeah
that's Europe no yeah
no yes brexit brother oh yeah
true absolutely not we are our own
Nation
where did you just get back from they're
[__] out of there I was in Lisbon
okay
so are you done now
finally really I'm home totally done
that's the whole bit that's why I
brought the bike I'm home
until I go back to the clubs what when's
that happening it's probably in two
weeks okay because I'm [__] insane
you get a little break at least yeah no
no I'm gonna chill for a minute looked
at the uh
the special is
it's almost done really it's gonna come
out scares the [__] out when
I don't know it's uh we got just like
some final notes on the edit and then
color and wow that's sick yeah that's
really sick yeah that's really exciting
thanks man I'm stoked you know it's it's
tough though was Europe
changed like how I look at things and
then I did the set so much differently
that they got their own version of it
so you should do a European special yes
yeah
yeah are you actually no no no damn you
should but dude you should put out a
special and have someone dub it over in
Italian
yeah oh that's that's Portuguese that's
Portuguese
oh yeah yeah yeah I know that yeah
obviously come on man I know I've been
to Europe and I've been around yeah
obviously I wouldn't know the
construction there well your pj's been a
lot of places yeah
yeah
yep what
it's funny
That's Italian for ciabatta
dude you are your dad
after meeting your dad especially in the
glasses yeah do you do you remember when
we had a quick breakfast that morning
yeah I know that's like what that's I
know exactly what you're gonna say
you remember his bit yeah I mean it's
one of the he still does that yeah so
much let's hear the bit
he just says cross gracias and then he
says that's Spanish for thank you yes
which is not really that funny but you
are your dad I know but
but that was my own little spin on it
yeah it was yeah yeah
I picture you guys doing that to each
other and you're both like
I did laugh the first couple times you
did it
but I think that's the thing about dad
jokes is that they don't go away yeah no
and you hear them over and over and over
again oh it's fine I think I think and
then eventually it gets funny again yeah
and you're like oh Dad and then
eventually it gets you know a little
racist yeah yeah see that's the thing is
um if you know if we have children
uh and my kids start making jokes do you
have children yeah I want to say that
like well you know we're getting married
we're married
you know we're gay we're gay
oh you said that you know we're gay well
yeah because we're gay yeah
well we [__] each other dude
obviously we're gonna get a kid
watch all the [__] gay sex we've had
we've got to have a kid
are you kidding me better yeah just with
the sheer amount yeah you guys think
it's a joke
we're putting in work we didn't even
want to do it but we know it was like we
had to at this point we've known each
other for so long we have to [__] but
you're saying when we have kids yeah
when we have kids
I just think you know
I think if I have a kid
I
want to be an [__] in that if he
starts trying to be funny
I'm gonna like try to headline him nice
yeah
in an annoying way like how so you know
like he'll he might let one off and I'll
be like no I'll be like
yeah no it makes a noise for my opener
I already feel bad for that kid
our kid our kid
and I'll be in the back like that was
funny yeah no that was good that was
good I know and I'll be like what was
the name that was funny I'll be like
yeah kid uh uh do you do you take
compliments from everybody or you take
the ones that matter
oh no he's bombing again
damn dude
yeah no no I won't do that